[Evans] A word is just something that has meaning
that speakers of the language will understand.
We could define words as just what's in the dictionary,
and then there would be a clear answer for that.
But certainly there are lots of things that are words that aren't in the dictionary.
And the important thing about words is we have rules for making new words.
For example, we have a rule that says if we have a word,
we can make a new word by adding counter in front of the old word.
I'm using the same notation that we used back in Unit 1.
This is the BNF replacement grammar.
If you need a refresher on this, please go back to the video that introduced that in Unit 1.
But the basic property is that we can replace what's on the left side
with what's on the right side.
So any time we have a word, we can replace it with counter-word,
and the meaning of the new word is something that goes against the original word.
So if we started with the word intelligence--
and I mean this in the sense of spycraft, not in terms of smarts--
then we can use the rule.
We could make the word counter-intelligence.
Intelligence was a word. We added counter in front of it to make counter-intelligence.
That means trying to thwart intelligence from the enemy.
We can use the rule again.
So now this is a word, and we could replace this word with counter in front of that word.
We get counter-counter-intelligence,
and that would be trying to thwart the enemy's counter-intelligence
that's preventing you from getting intelligence.
And we could keep doing that.
We could have counter-counter-counter-intelligence and so forth.
These are words that once we get up to at least 3 counters
it's not something that's used before, but it's still something that has a sensible meaning.
We could do this for other words.
We saw that one of the very long words was this hippopotomonstrosesquippedaliophobia.
If you knew that this word meant fear of long words,
and even if you've never seen the word counter in front of that before,
now we can make the new word counter-hippopotomonstrosesquippedaliophobia.
Quite a mouthful.
But even though you've never seen that word before--
and I expect most of you have never seen that word before--
you could guess that this is something that goes against the fear of long words.
Maybe there's some new medication that cures people of this phobia.
You could also figure out if there was a counter-counter-hippo and so forth phobia,
that would be something that counteracts the counter-hippo,
and that might be something where this new drug doesn't work if you have too much coffee.
Then coffee would be a counter-counter-hippo so forth phobia.
So the point is, because English has this rule that allows us to make new words
from old words, there's no such thing as the longest word.
We could always make a longer word starting from any word that we have.
If you remember how BNF grammars work,
then you should be able to answer the next quiz.